un nouveau théâtre national ouvre ses
portes ce soir avec une salle
ultramoderne et une belle affiche
michel bouquet denise gence pour ne
citer qu'eux alors ce théâtre nouveau
s'installe dans les yvelines à saint
quentin
deux salles une médiathèque de la danse
de la musique dans un lieu christine le
errants qui mélange béton et théâtre à
l'italienne christine oui à ce soir
c'est un grand moment pour la vie de
nouvelles de 50 ha qui voit aboutir un
projet vieux de plus d'une dizaine
d'années à leur programme l'évocation de
ce que sera ce lieu culturel le sens que
l'on va lui donner
éclectisme pas d'à priori du classique
au contemporain avec notamment ce soir
la présence de tony gans mais aussi des
musiciens et des danseurs alors le
bâtiment en lui-même c'est l'option
béton brut ce mariage des structures
métalliques et il a été réalisé par un
architecte polonais l'intérieur c'est
une salle de spectacles de 1000 places
avec fosse pour leurs caisses les
plusieurs lieux qui correspondent
effectivement à sa vocation culturelle
comme des salles d'exposition
le résultat rechi textural est à l'image
du centre-ville de saint-quentin créé de
toutes pièces depuis ces vingt dernières
années
saint quentin à la recherche de son arme
pour devenir une ville comme les autres
et à qui il manquait à grand lieu de
rencontre il ya l'église vit à l'hôtel
de ville
william hôpital et yann théâtre parce
que le théâtre est un lieu en plus où
des gens ou des hommes et des femmes se
rassemblent se rassemble sans doute pour
entendre un message ou simplement un
message qui peut être de pur
divertissement mais aussi parce que je
pense que les hommes sont ont besoin de
chaleur
et comme me le signaler tout à l'heure
le directeur du théâtre les habitants
des villes nouvelles n'auront plus
besoin de parcourir des kilomètres pour
aller au théâtre on enregistre près de
quatre mille abonnements pour la saison
un bon début selon directeur qui se
lance avec toute son équipe dans une
aventure culturelle tel un pari sur
l'avenir